THIS IS THE FIVE.
FOX NEWS ALERT, QUEEN ELIZABETH
II HAS DIED ENDING THE LONGEST
RULE IN GREAT BRITAIN'S HISTORY.
THE 96-YEAR-OLD MONARCH PASSING
AWAY PEACEFULLY THIS AFTERNOON
SURROUNDED BY THE ROYAL FAMILY
RUSHING TO BE BUSINESS HER
BEDSIDE AT HER COUNTRY ESTATE IN
THE SCOTTISH HIGHLANDS.
CROWDS GATHERING OUTSIDE
BUCKINGHAM PALACE ALL DAY TO
MOURN THE LOSS OF THEIR BELOVED
ICON.
PRINCE CHARLES IS NOW THE KING
OF ENGLAND, THE KING CONSORT
WITH THE OFFICIAL TITLE OF KING
CHARLES III.
CHARLES CALLING HIS MOTHER'S
DEATH A MOMENT OF GREAT SADNESS
FOR HIM AND THE ROYAL FAMILY.
NEWLY INSTALLED BRITISH PRIME
MINISTER LIZ TRUSS MET WITH THE
QUEEN TWO DAYS AGO ADDRESSING
THE NATION.
>> IT IS A DAY OF GREAT LOSS BUT
QUEEN ELIZABETH II LEAVES A
GREAT LEGACY.
TODAY THE CROWN PASSES AS IT HAS
DONE FOR MORE THAN 1,000 YEARS
TO OUR NEW MONARCH, OUR NEW HEAD
OF STATE, HIS MAJESTY KING
CHARLES III.
WE USHER IN A NEW ERA IN THE
MAGNIFICENT HISTORY OF OUR GREAT
COUNTRY.
EXACTLY AS HER MAJESTY WOULD
HAVE WISHED.
BY SAYING THE WORDS, GOD SAVE
THE KING.
>> THE NEWS BREAKING THIS
MORNING, JUDGE, AROUND 8:00 WHEN
HER DOCTORS ISSUE ADD STATEMENT
SAYING WE'RE CONCERNED FOR HER
HEALTH AND THE BRITT HAVES A WAY
OF UNDERSTATING THINGS AND THAT
SET OFF EVERY TO KNOW THIS COULD
BE IT AND UNFORTUNATELY IT WAS.
THE LIKE WHAT THE PRIME MINISTER
SAID, A GREAT LEGACY.
>> SHE DID HAVE A GREAT LEGACY.
SHE'S THE ONLY QUEEN I'VE EVER
KNOWN AND MOST OF THE PEOPLE IN
THE LAST 70 YEARS HAVE KNOWN
ANYWAY AND AS A AMERICAN, I
LOOKED AT HER AS SOMEONE THAT
WAS INCREDIBLY STRONG.
WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT ALL THE
YEARS THAT SHE WAS THE QUEEN,
SHE HAD A FRONT ROW SEAT TO
HISTORY.
SHE WAS THE QUEEN WHEN WINSTON
CHURCHHILL WAS PRIME MINISTER
AND DURING WORLD WAR II, SHE WAS
A DRIVER AND MECHANIC AND PART
OF THE WOMEN'S AUXILIARY AND SHE
WAS A TOUGH WOMAN AND WOMEN TRY
TO BALANCE WORK AND WORKPLACE
AND HOME IN THE '60S AND '70S
AND SHE WAS A YOUNG WOMAN, A
QUEEN AT 24, A MOTHER, A WIFE,
RUNNING A COUNTRY AND SHE DID IT
ALL WITH SUCH ELEGANCE, SUCH
CALM, SUCH FINESSE.
SHE WAS SO STOIC AND THEN YOU
THINK ABOUT HER WITH PEOPLE WITH
RONALD REAGAN, RIDING HORSES
WITH RONALD REAGAN AND MARGARET
THATCHER AND ANOTHER TOUGH WOMAN
JUST AS THE QUEEN WAS.
SHE WAS TO ME THE ESSENCE OF
BALANCE.
SHE'S GONE THROUGH SO MUCH IN
THE LAST FEW YEARS AND YET SHE
REMAINED STOIC AND KIND AND
APPARENTLY A VERY GIVING WOMAN,
AND SHE IS REALLY A -- SOMEONE
THAT WE CAN ALL MODEL OURSELVES
AFTER IN TERMS OF HER ABILITY TO
DEAL WITH STRESS AND BE THE
WOMAN WHO CAN RUN A HOUSE AND A
COUNTRY.
>> IN FACT, WHEN YOU MENTION
MARGARET THATCHER, IT MAKES ME
THINK THAT MARGARET THATCHER AND
QUEEN ELIZABETH WERE THE TWO
MOST POWERFUL WOMEN IN THE
WORLD.
HER FIRST OFFICIAL ASSIGNMENT IS
TO TAKE THE NATION THROUGH THE
FUNERAL PROCESS.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
SOMETHING INCREDIBLY SPECIAL FOR
PRIME MINISTER TRUSS TO GET THAT
OPPORTUNITY AND CAN'T HELP THINK
THAT IT WAS 48 HOURS LATER THAT
THE QUEEN WANTED TO BE THERE AND
IT WAS IMPORTANT TO BE THERE AND
STAND WITH THE NEXT PRIME
MINISTER AND A FEMALE PRIME
MINISTER AND WELCOME HER INTO
THAT ROLE AND HER DUTIES ARE
LARGELY CEREMONIAL THERE AS WITH
THE PRIME MINISTER.
I LIVED IN LONDON FOR SIX YEARS
AND THERE FOR THE ROYAL WEDDING
WHEN WILL AND KATE GOT MARRIED,
WHICH WAS -- YOU COULDN'T HELP
BUT GET INTO IT.
THAT'S THE THING.
WHATEVER YOU THINK ABOUT
MONARCHY AND WE CAN HAVE
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT HISTORY OF
COLONIALISM AND ALL OF THAT,
IT'S SPECIAL.
THE PLACE THAT THESE ROYALS HOLD
IN THE HEARTS OF THE PEOPLE IN
THE UK AND ACROSS THE
COMMONWEALTH IS NOT SOMETHING TO
BE TRIFLED WITH AND I LOVE IT
AND LOVE BEING APART OF IT AND
HAVING THE OPPORTUNITY TO SIT
THERE AND KIND OF SEE ALL THE
BUNTING COME OUT AND THE
EXCITEMENT TO CATCH A GLIMPSE OF
THEM.
I KNOW EVERYONE IS SHARING ALL
THE INCREDIBLE STORIES FROM HER
LIFE, BUT I HAVE TO SAY I -- ANY
TIME THAT VIDEO IS CIRCULATED OF
WHAT SHE DID ON SEPTEMBER 12
WHERE SHE HAD THEM PLAY THE STAR
SPANGLED BANNER AFTER
SEPTEMBER 11 HERE, IT'S JUST --
YOU CAN'T HELP BUT CRY AT THESE
KINDS OF GESTURES BRINGING 600
YEARS OF TRADITION TO UPHOLD THE
SPECIAL RELATIONSHIP THAT THE
U.S. AND UK HAS.
SHE REALLY USHERED IN THE
MONARCHY INTO A MORE MODERN ERA
AND DID IT SO SEAMLESSLY FROM
HOW SHE DRESSED TO HOW SHE
TREATED PEOPLE.
THE WAY SHE IS WITH HER GRAND
KIDS, CERTAINLY AFTER DIANA DIED
AND WITH HER A GREAT
GRANDCHILDREN, MUCH RESPECT.
>> ANGWILL KELLY WROTE A --
ANGELA KELLY WROTE A BOOK ABOUT
THE QUEEN AND THE PLANNING OF
ALL THE OUTFITS AND JESSE I KNOW
THOUGHT ALL DAY ABOUT HIS OUTFIT
AND WHAT TO WEAR.
THE GIRLS HAVE GONE ON LONG
ENOUGH SO YOUR TURN.
>> I DON'T HAVE AS DEEP A
THOUSANDS AS THE GIRLS BUT WE
HAVE A SPECIAL RELATIONSHIP WITH
THE BRITISH HISTORICALLY AND
MANY PEOPLE ARE WATCHING AND
DON'T REALLY CARE AS MUCH AS
OTHER AMERICANS OR OTHER PEOPLE
IN THE COMMONWEALTH, BUT THIS IS
WHY IT'S IMPORTANT.
MANY PEOPLE FROM GREAT BRITAIN
CAME FROM THE UNITED STATES TO
COLUMBIA LONIZE IT AND WENT
TO -- COLONIZE IT AND I
UNDERSTAND THAT AND WHAT SHE
REPRESENTED WAS MORE THAN THE
MONARCHY.
IT WAS THE BRITISH EMPIRE AND AT
THAT TIME.
IT WAS THE GREATEST EMPIRE IN
THE ENTIRE WORLD HAS EVER SEEN
AND THE UNITED STATES CAME AND
RESCUED THE BRITISH FROM WORLD
WAR II FROM THE GERMANS AND TOLD
THEM TO GET RID OF THEIR
COLONIES AND THEY'VE LOST A LOT
OF POWER.
WE STILL HAVE THIS SPECIAL
RELATIONSHIP WITH GREAT BRITAIN
AND WHEN A MONARCH DICED LIKE
THIS, AMERICANS SEE THE
RELATIONSHIP THROUGH THE EYES OF
HER RELATIONSHIP WITH OUR
PRESIDENTS.
EVERY PRESIDENT THE COMES INTO
OFFICE THEY GO AND THEY GO TO
LONDON AND MEET THE QUEEN.
IF YOU ASK THE PRESIDENTS,
PROBABLY MIGHT BE ONE OF THE
MOST SPECIAL IF NOT THE MOST
SPECIAL MOMENTS OF THEIR
PRESIDENCY.
SHE REPRESENTS MORE THAN A PRIME
MINISTER AND WE DON'T HAVE
PEOPLE LIKE THAT ANYMORE AND
GIVES YOU THE CHILLS TO THINK
ABOUT IT AND RISES ABOVE
POLITICS AND REPUBLICANS AND
DEMOCRATS, YOU ADMIRE THIS
WOMAN.
IF THERE'S A WAR, CONTROVERSY,
SOCIAL INJUSTICE, SHE HAS THIS
GRACEFUL WAY OF RISING ABOVE IT
AND JUST DOING WHAT'S BEST FOR
HER PEOPLE AND DOING WHAT'S BEST
FOR THE WORLD.
THAT'S SOMETHING VERY
SIGNIFICANT.
WE DON'T HAVE PEOPLE LIKE THAT
ANYMORE AND THAT'S THE REASON
PEOPLE SHOULD PAY ATTENTION TO
THIS BECAUSE WE'RE IN A NEW ERA
NOW WHETHER WE LIKE IT OR NOT.
>> RICHARD, YEAH, THERE'S
SOMETHING ABOUT TRADITION THAT
PEOPLE TEND TO LIKE; RIGHT.
I KNOW YOU'RE --
>> I'M A BIG PRO TRADITION, VERY
PROTRADITION.
I WAS STRUCK WHEN YOU SAID THAT
DOCTORS WERE VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT HER HEALTH.
SHE'S 96.
YEAH.
>> BUT THEY NEVER SAY THAT.
>> YEAH, BUT SHE'S 96.
THEY WERE CONCERNED ABOUT HER
HEALTH EVERY DAY.
JIMMY CARTER, 97.
THERE YOU GO.
SHE CLEARLY LIVED A UNIQUE LIFE.
IT'S ONE THING TO BE A QUEEN,
BUT IT'S ANOTHER THING TO LIVE
TO BE PRACTICALLY 100.
THINK ABOUT THAT COMBINATION.
THAT'S LIKE WINNING THE LOTTERY.
NOT ONLY WERE YOU ROYALTY, BUT
FOR A CENTURY YOU WERE ROYALTY.
I WOULD BE HAPPY LIVING TO BE
100 OR BEING THE ROYALTY BUT TO
GET BOTH IS INCREDIBLE.
THINK ABOUT IT, WHAT KILLED HER?
HAVE YOU THOUGHT ABOUT THAT?
WAS IT OLD AGE OR THE FACT THAT
THEY STOPPED HER FROM DRINKING
HER MARTINIS.
THIS IS WHAT I WILL NEVER
UNDERSTAND --
>> DID THEY DO THAT?
>> YES!
WHEN PEOPLE GET OLDER, THEY DID
THIS WITH MY MOTHER, PEOPLE GET
OLDER AND SAY MAYBE IT'LL SAVE
YOU A MONTH.
SHE COULDN'T DRINK HER MARTINIS
ANYMORE.
THAT DOESN'T MAKE YOU LIVE
LONGER, IT MAKES YOU THINK
YOU'RE LIVING LONGER BECAUSE IT
FEELS THAT WAY.
MEANWHILE SHE CAN'T DRINK WHILE
DEALING WITH MEGHAN MARKLE AND
THAT WOULD DRIVE ANYBODY TO
DRINK AND SHE CAN'T DRINK.
IT WOULD BE HAVE BEEN NICER IF
THEY LET HER HAVE HER NIGHTLY
STIPPLE.
THAT WAS TERRIBLE.
SHE HAD A NONEQUALLY CHARMED
LIFE AND CHALLENGING LIFE AT
THAT AND LOOKING FORWARD TO THE
NEW MONARCHY AND IS IT A WOKE
MONARCHY?
>> LOT OF CLIMATE CHANGE.
>> A LOT OF CLIMATE CHANGE WILL
HAPPEN.
>> SHOULD WE ALL HAVE A MARTINI
ON BEHALF OF HER TONIGHT.
>> YEAH, POUR ONE OUT FOR OUR
HOMIE.
>> ANYBODY ELSE HAVE FINAL
THOUGHTS?
>> THE PEOPLE ON TV TALKING
ABOUT HER PERSONALLY, ONE THING
I THOUGHT WAS FASCINATING WAS
THAT THEY SAID SHE HAD LIKE A
FUNNY SIDE, A HAPPY SIDE, AND
SHE DID THAT PADDINGTON BEAR
SKIT WHERE SHE'S HAVING TEA WITH
PADDINGTON BEAR AND AT ONE POINT
SHE JUMPED OUT OF A HELICOPTER
AT LIKE 75 OR SOMETHING.
SHE DID SOMETHING WITH DANIEL
CRAIG FOR --
>> FOR THE OLYMPICS.
>> YEAH, SHE WASN'T AFRAID TO
MIX IT UP.
ALL THE STOICISM WE SAW.
BY THE WAY, SHE PUT THE PEDAL TO
THE METAL.
I HEAR SHE DROVE LIKE A BAT OUT
OF HELL.
>> THAT'S THE STORY WITH THE
SAUDI CROWN PRINCE AND WAS
VISITING AND WOMEN CAN'T DRIVE
AND SHE GOT INTO THE DRIVER'S
SEAT AND SHOCKED BECAUSE SHE WAS
WIZZING AROUND AND HE'S --
WHIZZING AROUND AND HE'S GOING
THROUGH HIS TRANSLATOR TO ASK
HER TO SLOW DOWN.
SLOW DOWN.
SHE DIDN'T SLOW DOWN ONE BIT.
>> IT WOULD BE INTERESTING TO
READ SOME OF HER DIRES ABOUT THE
TIME DURING THE -- DIARIES
DURING THE TIME IN THE COLD WAR
AND ALLIES TRYING TO FIND A WAY
TO BREAK COMMUNISM AND I WAS
NERVOUS TO MEET HER IN 2008 AND
DEPUTY CHIEF OF STAFF PUSHED ME
FORWARD TO MEET THE QUEEN AND
HAD A CHANCE TO SIGH HI TO HER.
>> WHAT IS THE PROTOCOL?
>> THERE'S A LIST A MILE LONG OF
THINGS YOU SHOULD OR SHOULDN'T
DO.
>> JUST LUNGE FORWARD.
>> WHAT DID YOU DO?
>> SOME PEOPLE HAD TO CURTESY
AND IT WAS A 45 SECONDS
CONVERSATION AND PRESIDENT BUSH
BROUGHT HER A ELECTRIC VEHICLE
GOLF CART THING AND HAD THE
UNION JACK ON IT.
>> THAT WASN'T GOOD AS OBAMA'S
PRESIDENT.
ALL OF HIS SPEECHES ON HIS CD TO
LISTEN TO.
>> ON AN I POD.
>> YOU HAD TO BASH A DEMOCRAT.
WE WERE HAVING A MOMENT.
>> I THOUGHT IT WAS A GREAT
GIFT.
SOMETHING I WOULD GIVE TO THE
QUEEN.
>> IT'S AMAZING HOW
CONSPICUOUSLY SILENT HE'S BE